hi everybody thanks so much for joining
us as we pay a special tribute to Penny
Marshall and you mentioned special
because we're standing in a special
place right in front of stage 15 it is
just a short walk from our set but this
is where penny made her last TV
appearance on the rebooted version of
The Odd Couple and easy was there of
course we went back and counted how many
times we were with penny over the years
and you're not gonna believe this but
astounding 109 times so we got to know
her very well she shared with us her
personal triumphs but also our private
struggles and you know what through it
all penny stayed just as feisty and
strong as her TV alter-ego Laverne
DeFazio crap happens in life you got to
deal with it
penny wasn't just the fighter but a
force to be reckoned with when et sat
down with penny in 2012 she was in
remission after a very public battle
with lung cancer that spread to her
brain she got very fired up talking
about the tabloid reports your battle of
cancer yeah has been very public because
the public is the stupid people because
the rags write about it and they get it
wrong and they die of me dying every
three months still and I'm fine she was
a regular person who just happened to
become famous and I don't think she ever
got forgot where she came from
today et was with her friend and former
TV love-interest Jay Leno who shared his
memories of their time together on
Laverne & Shirley hey sure split what
and leave Laverne unchaperoned you know
I was a new comedian it was probably the
height of her stardom with the furniture
they were huge stars she was so kind and
nice to me it came as such a shock it
really was one thing everyone in
Hollywood knew about penny family came
first her own brother
the late Gary Marshall launched her
career in the 1970 series The Odd Couple
mr. I am NOT
I wouldn't have a career if it wasn't
with my brothers oh I'd say I thank my
brother I always thought he was being
nice to me
he's just being nice because I'm a
sister and he told me that nobody is
that nice I'm not that nice et's last
sit-down with penny was in 2016 Gary's
son Scott conducted the interview when a
Gary mean to you he gave me a lie if he
was my older brother who was raised
thank you are a pest
there's the Laverne that we love the
feisty Laverne coming out of penny there
[Music]